what i want to do in this video is give
ourselves a quick overview of the
different ways that cells can
communicate with each other and maybe
the most basic one is just through
direct contact
direct contact and this can happen
several different ways one way could be
you just have neighboring cells so this
is one cell right over here
and this is the neighboring cell right
over here
and they actually might have gaps in
their membranes if these are plant cells
we would call these gaps gap junctions
so you might have i just drew two of
them and this is obviously just kind of
a two-dimensional slice so we're not
fully appreciating the three-dimensional
structure but the basic idea is is maybe
the cell on the left starts producing
some molecules especially some small
molecules that are able to go through
these gap junctions and when they're
able to go through the gap junctions
maybe they latch on to some proteins in
the second cell that start maybe
activating them in a certain way or
inhibit them in a certain way or trigger
some type of reaction and so then you
have a
response
in the second cell so this would be a
form of communication something happened
in this first cell to produce these
molecules those molecules were able to
get into the second cell and trigger a
response and as i mentioned if these are
animal cells we would call these gaps
we'd call them gap junctions
so
that right over there that is a gap
junction
gap junction
and we covered this in other videos and
if we're talking about plant cells we
can have very similar things happening
but we wouldn't call them gla gap
junctions we would actually these would
be gaps not just through the not even
tunnels through the membrane it would
also be through the cell walls if they
were talking about plants they would be
plasmodesmata
plas
mo
desmond we talk about these more in the
in the structure of cell videos but
there's other ways that you could
communicate via direct contact you could
imagine maybe some cells that are
floating around in the bloodstream
maybe this is one cell over here
maybe
maybe this is another cell over here
and they have complementary surface
proteins surface proteins that are able
to bind to each other so maybe this one
has a surface protein that looks like
this i'm obviously exaggerating its
shape the protein wouldn't look exactly
like this inverted triangle but this one
has a surface protein like this and i'm
also exaggerating its size relative to a
cell just so we can
appreciate how they could maybe lock
together
so this one has a surface protein like
that and when they bind to each other it
might change the proteins in some way
and then trigger a reaction in each of
these cells that the communication then
continues if this protein changes a
little bit it might activate something
it might activate the release of some
molecules might activate some other
proteins might catalyze some type of
reaction we've seen this in multiple
other videos all sorts of crazy
biological reactions can happen inside
of cells but it might elicit a it could
elicit
a response and actually could even
elicit a response in both cells
some type of response they know that
they are latched on they know that
they're latched on to someone else
now direct contact you could imagine is
not the only way that you could have
cell cell signaling you could actually
have cells start to signal over a little
bit of a distance by releasing molecules
into the extracellular space and
eventually even into the bloodstream
so
for example
let me draw a cell
a cell right over here
and maybe it's able to produce some
molecules
and these molecules either they might be
lipid soluble and maybe make their way
through the cellular membrane on their
own or
maybe they are
packed in nice vesicles that allow them
to traverse the membrane so when you get
actually
so the membrane of the vesicle merges
with the membrane of the cell
and then it allows
these things to
get out
and so you can imagine if another cell
has the right receptors for these that
would signal that would signal some type
of a response or it will form some form
of communication so
let's say that i have actually draw a
couple of cells so let's say i have this
cell over here
and then i have
this cell over here
and
let's say that this cell has the right
receptor
has the right receptor
and this cell doesn't it could have
other receptors maybe it has receptors
like
that but it's not the right receptor and
so these these molecules that were
released by this first cell could bind
not on this character not on this
protein this surface protein but it
could bind on this character
so it could bind on this character
and when it does so this protein that's
on the on the on the cellular membrane
it might change its shape it might do
all sorts of things but that signal can
be then taken somehow being it can be
it can continue on into the cell and
once again you might elicit some type of
response and we'll go into more detail
in future videos on exactly how that
happens or what these responses actually
might be
now if this is over if this is over a
short distance
if this is over if this is a short
distance
short
if this is a short distance
distance
we would call this paracrine this would
this would be part of the paracrine
system where we would call this
paracrine communication
let me write that down
paracrine
system
or paracrine communication or paracrine
signaling and we would call these
paracrine factors but it was happening
over long distances
say maybe these these molecules they
enter into the bloodstream
so they make their way into the
bloodstream right over here so let me
depict somehow that this is the
bloodstream so this is
the bloodstream
bloodstream and they're able to make and
they're able to go through the
bloodstream over longer distances
to other molecules
to other molecules so maybe this one has
the right receptors
for those
for those molecules then we call this
endocrine system or this is endocrine
signaling so long distances
long
long distances
we would call this the endocrine system
or endocrine
endocrine signaling
endocrine
signaling and we're talking about the
endocrine system and endocrine signaling
these molecules which could just be you
know there could be all sorts of
different types of molecules they could
be steroids they could be proteins of
some kind we call in this case we would
call them hormones and you've probably
heard the word before and we will do a
whole series of videos on hormones but
these molecules actually can even affect
the cell that produced them for example
the cell that produced it might have the
right receptor
might have the right receptor and so if
it's able to signal if it's able to
trigger a reaction in itself so if these
things are able to trigger a reaction in
itself we would call that an autocrine
process
autocrine it is acting on itself and
just so you're familiar with some of the
terminology
these proteins on the surface and this
would be the case especially if you have
a if you if you have non-lipid soluble
types of of signaling factors or
molecules right over here these proteins
well actually even if they're on the
surface or even if they're within the
cell we would call them receptors
so that right over there that is a
receptor
and the molecules themselves these
things that bind onto the receptor we
call them the ligand
ligand in general it's a general term
for something that binds onto a receptor
and so what at that point where you bind
onto a receptor whether you're talking
about the parrot or perricken process or
endocrine endo
actually endo i'll have to see out here
endocrine
signaling
this this process where it kind of
starts to where it latches on we would
call that a signal perception and then
when this protein
you know somehow changes its shape or
starts catalyzing reaction or inhibiting
a reaction
we would call this the signal
transduction
it's bringing the signal into the cell
and then you have and then you have your
actual
you have your actual cellular response
so hopefully you appreciate that as just
a bit of a an overview of how cells can
signal with each other in future videos
we'll go into a little bit more detail
especially the endocrine system and our
understanding of hormones